[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
abend der morgige nato gipfel in madrid
dürfte einer der wichtigsten seit langer
zeit werden allein schon wegen der
meldung die vor gut einer stunde kam
finnland und schweden können der nato
beitreten
die türkei hat nach langem widerstand
und harten verhandlungen dafür bereits
jetzt am vorabend grünes licht gegeben
damit wird dieser gipfel schon ein
historischer darüber hinaus muss sich
das bündnis neu aufstellen eine
strategie für das nächste jahrzehnt
mindestens entwickeln in gewisser weise
könnte man sagen back to the roots es
geht wieder um landesverteidigung im
klassischen sinne und der alte feind ist
auch der neue und sitzt in moskau die
hauptpreise berichtet es war eine
einigung um fünf vor zwölf die türkei
zieht ihr veto gegen eine nato
mitgliedschaft finnlands und schwedens
zurück beide länder erklären sich bereit
türkische forderungen zur verschärfung
des anti terror kampfes zu erfüllen ihr
weg in die nato ist frei
die türkei finnland und schweden haben
ein memorandum unterzeichnet
dies ist mein brandung konnte die
bedenken der türkei ausräumen es
beinhaltet auch waffenexporte und den
kampf gegen den terrorismus
es waren solche bilder die die türkische
regierung zur weißglut brachten
schwedens außenministerin an linde im
roten kleid lässt sich mit vertretern
der syrischen kurden ablichten im
schwedischen parlament wetter die
abgeordnete amini kkw ehemalige
kurdische guerilla kämpferin gegen die
türkische kurden politik auf
demonstrationen in schweden wie in pkk
fahnen zu lax sei der umgang schwedens
mit terroristen hatte ankara immer
wieder protestiert
das thema pkk ist in der türkei ein sehr
wichtiges sowohl für jede regierung als
auch für die türkische öffentlichkeit
das allein bestimmt bereits die
türkische position und das ist auch
nichts neues seit langer zeit schon hat
die türkische regierung ihre denkt in
stockholm gezeigt
die regierungsnahe zeitung hürriyet
veröffentlichte gestern die bilder
kurdischer terrorverdächtiger die sich
in skandinavien aufhalten erdogan
verlangt deren auslieferung in jedem
falle aber eine verschärfung der anti
terror gesetze
es geht darum dass diese länder die
strukturen der pkk bekämpfen deren
einfluss deren finanzierungs und
rekrutierungs system das ist etwas das
die schwedische regierung tun kann und
tun sollte
bei dem treffen heute in madrid haben
die scandinavia offenbar diese
forderungen an karas erfüllt präsident
erdogan wusste um seine vetomacht nutzte
sie auch um ein jahr vor den wahlen in
der türkei beim eigenen volk zu punkt
bei dem nato thema reagiert die
türkische gesellschaft sehr sensibel
nationalismus und konservatismus sind in
der türkei sehr stark ausgeprägt deshalb
verzeichnet die regierung seit beginn
der nato krise einen ernsthaften
stimmenzuwachs von 10%
anti-terror-kampf ist auch wahlkampf der
präsident braucht starke auftritte da
kam ihm der nato-gipfel gerade recht
jetzt schauen mit florian hahn der den
für uns in madrid beobachtet schauen wir
auf die aufnahme von schweden und
finnland finnland ein land das eine über
1000 kilometer lange grenze zu russland
an da fragt man sich natürlich schon was
bedeutet das für die nato also
generalsekretär stoltenberg hat vorhin
in der pressekonferenz gesagt für putin
heißt das motto des borders
ja in der tat ich würde sagen da passt
dieses längst abgedroschene wort der
zeitenwende diesmal wirklich
das ist eine erweiterung von der man in
der nato vor einigen monaten noch nicht
mal den kühnsten träumen gewagt hätte
daran zu denken
anders aber als bei den letzten
erweiterung in richtung osten sind es
diesmal nicht die staaten osteuropas die
von der neuen erweiterung profitieren
sondern es ist die nato die von dieser
neuen sicherheit profitiert das hat auch
den nato generalsekretärs deutenberg
gerade noch einmal betont er sprach
davon dass die beiden staaten besonders
leistungsfähige armeen haben und das ist
besonders wichtig für die vielleicht
verletzlichste flanke der nato im
baltikum nämlich in einem immer noch
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass russland
hier angreifen könnte da könnten neben
die truppen aus schweden und finnland
direkt diesen baltischen staaten zu
hilfe eilen auch über die ostsee die
dann ein meer der nato geben wird wenn
schweden und finnland beigetreten sind
ja und schließlich passiert das ganze zu
einem zeitpunkt wo die nato ohnehin
aufrüstet wo sie sich auf ihre alten
wurzeln zurück besinnt auf die
verteidigung und abschreckung gegen
russland und da werden diese beiden
neuen staaten wenn sie denn beigetreten
sind enorm helfen indem zusammen 1 geht
zusammenhang eines der heikelsten themen
sind natürlich die waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine baut man da geht panzer ja
oder nein was deine einschätzung wird
darüber morgen in madrid auch diskutiert
werden
auf jeden fall einen deshalb weil morgen
sich der ukrainische präsident wolle die
mesa lenski per video an die spitzen der
nato richten wird natürlich wird sie
lenski wieder einmal ein appell richten
dass man doch mehr und schwere waffen
benötige um in diesem krieg noch
bestehen zu können und wir erleben dass
da ein tabu nach dem anderen fällt
bisher galt die devise dass die nato als
organisation sich aus diesem thema der
waffenlieferungen noch besser heraus
hält das einfach die einzelnen staaten
liefern nicht aber die nato diese grenze
verschwimmt zusehends jetzt ist es die
nato die offen darüber diskutiert und es
fallen auch andere tabus etwa die frage
welche schweren waffen geliefert werden
zusehens liefern nato staaten nur noch
schwere moderne westliche waffen dazu
passt auch die ankündigung von heute
abend von deutschland und den
niederlanden dass man sechs weitere
panzerhaubitzen 2000 in die ukraine
schicken will und denen ist er bereits
einige in der ukraine im einsatz gibt es
gibt vielleicht doch ein allerletztes
kleines tabu das ist nämlich dass bisher
kein westlicher nato-staat kampfpanzer
westlicher bauart in die ukraine
geschickt hat aber auch über dieses tabu
wird längst innerhalb der nato
diskutiert und es wird in frage gestellt
insofern man ist sich hier in der nato
relativ sicher man muss diese ukraine
damit sie bestehen kann auf lange sicht
unterstützen und man ist dafür auch
bereit über bisher gesetzte rote grenzen
zu gehen dankeschön florian nach madrid
und noch der hinweis auf eine doku
unsere korrespondenten florian neuhann
und unna krüger mit dem titel come back
der nato wie putins krieg die allianz
verändert sie finden sie schon jetzt
jederzeit in unserer mediathek
beziehungsweise heute de und dem zdf 40
morgen abend um 0 45 ausgestrahlt
in madrid sehen sich jedenfalls auch die
sieben wieder die gerade erst in ellmau
drei tage miteinander verbrachten
persönliche gespräche mal zu zweit oder
dritt eine runde spazieren gehen in
überschaubaren kreis diskutieren ohne
dass vorher schon starr festgelegt ist
wer wann und wie lang ein vorbereitetes
statement vorträgt und dann abends an
der bar stehen und auch mal ungelöst
undiplomatisch schreiben können das ist
es was staats und regierungschefs an dem
g7-gipfel mögen und dazu waren sie
ursprünglich auch mal gedacht inzwischen
wird aber mehr erwartet allein schon
weil der aufwand so gigantisch geworden
ist was hat dieser gipfel also gebracht
simon franz it zieht eine bilanz
dass die george marshall statue in
garmisch partenkirchen heute ziemlich im
regen steht passt eigentlich nicht zu
diesem tag seine idee sein name sein
plan sie werden heute zitiert als es
oben vor schloss elmau aus um die
zukunft der unfreiwilligen wir brauchen
einen marshallplan für die ukraine der
muss auch gut geplant und entwickelt
werden das hat uns vorgenommen es ist
ein blick nach vorn in richtung
wiederaufbau mit dem dieses treffen in
den alpen zu ende geht der krieg hat den
gipfel dominiert an jedem der drei tage
die gleiche beschwörung wir stehen an
der seite der ukraine wir sind uns
einig präsident putin darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen
wir werden weiter die wirtschaftlichen
und politischen kosten dieses krieges
für präsident putin und sein regime
hochhalten und in die höhe treiben wer
eine serviert dem anderen kaffeefreunde
unter sich das ist die botschaft
doch ohne tatsächlich da zu sein sitzt
putin mit am tisch sie müssen sich mit
ihm beschäftigen ob es nun um den krieg
selbst geht die energieversorgung die
welternährung die die g7 russland etwa
zur freigabe der für getreideexporte so
wichtige ukrainischen häfen bringen
wollen darauf gibt es keine antwort aber
sie wollen weitere milliarden für den
kampf gegen den hunger bereitstellen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass es keine
nahrungsmittelknappheit keine hungersnot
keine falsche verteilung gibt wir müssen
bedrohten ländern dabei helfen in sehr
kurzer zeit mehr selbst zu produzieren
gifte wie sie ihre klimaziele einhalten
wollen während einige von ihnen neue gas
partnerschaften jenseits von russland
suchen es bleibt offen
aber sie bekennen sich zum 1,5 grad zu
wissen sie das ist ein notfall wer ist
nun aber niemand hat auf diesem gipfel
den willen geäußert dass dieser notfalls
ein abweichen von unseren klimazielen
rechtfertig kann oder rechtfertigen wird
kein justify justify
departure frommer kleine tages
auch am letzten tag liegt das dröhnen
der helikopter über der region für den
bundeskanzler weiß der erste g 7 gipfel
und er findet dass der ein erfolg war
dann verlassen die großen 7 das schloss
sie fahren einer ungewissen zukunft
entgegen
im november ist g20-gipfel wladimir
putin hat schon zugesagt
zu jedem gipfelteilnehmern die zumindest
den bildern nach hier und da für gute
laune sorgten gehörte britanniens prime
minister bus trotz der brekzie tier der
für die eu nach wie vor für probleme und
ärger sorgt aber zugleich weiterhin so
wichtig ist für den globalen westen für
das transatlantische bündnis
christian sievers weil die letzten tage
in ellmau und so hatte er dort heute
gelegenheit mit boris johnson
ausführlich zu sprechen über die ukraine
über putin und die weltlage im
allgemeinen
boris johnson ist bei uns der britische
premierminister
ja sie können das nicht eingeladen so
ist ist die welt nach diesem g7-gipfel
eine bessere eine sicherere
ja ich die welt sicherer und besser ich
glaube das haben sie gesagt
na ja
man kann vielleicht folgendermaßen
formulieren als wir beschlossen elmar
kamen haben sehr viele medienvertreter
gesagt kann in deutschland überhaupt
einen solchen gipfel zum erfolg führen
können wir zu einer deutlichen botschaft
kaum über ukraine die ukraine oder was
anderes und wirklich es waren
hervorragende tage weil wir wirklich
zusammengewachsen sind
die logik ist folgende
natürlich will man dass das dass der
krieg zu ende geht man ist wirklich
verzweifelt man will das ende mal ein
ende kommt aber es wird keinen deal
geben dass angeboten der angeboten
werden wird kann deal anbieten zielinski
hat keinen deal anbieten und wir
haben uns darauf geeinigt dass wir
versuchen müssen sie es geht zu helfen
die dynamik irgendwie zu kippen die
position in der iss zu verbessern und
die ukraine haben ja auch gezeigt dass
sie an gegenangriffen können sehr
erfolgreich und wir haben entschieden
dass wir neben der humanitären und
wirtschaftlichen hilfe wie der sensibel
gefühl hatte etwa 30 milliarden dollar
zugesagt wirtschaftliche humanitäre
hilfe für die ukraine das ist ein großer
betrag
und die länder haben aber auch gesagt
wir helfen jetzt bei der militärischen
strategie aber ich glaube was viele
viele menschen in deutschland und
sicherlich auch in großbritannien
umtreibt ist die frage wie lange wird es
dauern
ich denke
einfach wird es nicht das kann ich nicht
behaupten das lässt sich schnell
erledigen aber was doch beeindruckend
war aus den gesprächen ist dass man
wirklich
grandios den ukrainern strategische
langen atem geben möchte und jeder
stimmt auch dass die ukrainische
regierung naja man kann natürlich
weniger werden als die ukraine die
müssen entscheiden was sie machen aber
wir wollen sollen helfen die beste
position zu kommen für gespräche wenn es
zu den westen zu gesprächen kommt das
ist die strategie zur zeit und
gleichzeitig möchten wir dafür sorgen
dass wir uns bereit machen der ukraine
die zusicherungen zu geben die die
ukraine braucht für die zukunft was
lieferung von nato waffen betrifft
ausbildung und nachrichtendienstliche
info damit man keinen angriff mehr hat
jetzt hat man herr premierminister
allerdings von ihnen ja auch noch eine
andere seite gesehen bei dem g7 gipfel
sie haben gleich ganz am anfang gemacht
haben gesagt wir sollten unsere jackett
ausziehen und wladimir putin unsere
muskeln zeigen ist das ihre art mit
putin umzugehen ihre strategie ihn
vielleicht auch ein bisschen lächerlich
zu machen ihn zu demaskieren
ja was ich ja gesagt habe ich habe das
gestern in einem anderen beitrag gesagt
in der debatte über
nahrungsmittelsicherheit haben und die
über geschlechtergleichheit und da war
ich auch ganz ehrlich und habe gesagt
das wichtigste ist ja dass man zwölf
jahre hochwertige bildung hat auch jedes
mädchen an jedes mädchen auf der welt
die gleiche bildung hätte wie ein junge
dann wären das hervorragenden sachen für
die menschheit für den planeten würden
dabei rauskommen und weil wir brauchen
einfach mehr frauen im positionen der
macht wenn putin eine frau dr
das war nicht aber wenn das wären dann
glaube ich nicht dass er eine solche
verrückten macho krieg vom zaun
gebrochen hätte rächen so wie es gemacht
hat als ein tolles beispiel finde ich
für toxische männlichkeit sie lehne sie
das ist das was er macht
sie haben gesagt dass das meeting dass
das sammelt hier der gipfel hat viel
gebracht nach zweieinhalb tagen mit
ihren kollegen hier spüren sie wie gut
es sein kann in einer starken union
zusammenzuarbeiten
die sind ja natürlich ist es gut und wir
haben ja auch solche kreise repeaters
mette sie haben uns gerade
zusammengesetzt queen als g7 und morgen
setzen wir uns zusammen als datum liegt
etwas über den exit
ich weiß dass es immer sehr viele
verschiedene meinungen dazu geben wird
und darf dazu untersagen je schneller
dieser punkt in vergessenheit gerät oder
in den hintergrund gerät
desto besser haben und glaub ich glaube
dass die stimmung sich jetzt gedreht und
zwar zum positiven sie haben ihre
unterstützung hierfür die ukraine im
kampf gegen russland verglichen mit dem
kampf gegen adolf hitler
ist das für sie wirklich eine
vergleichbarkeit
strecke ich wollte darauf hinaus
dass demokratien und touran ein sich
unterscheiden und in der geschichte war
es immer so dass es eine zeit gedauert
hat bis die demokratien
ende wirklich ihren weg gefunden haben
den mut gefunden haben zu reagieren auf
tyranneien türen ein können schneller
agieren weil sie eben keine
demokratischen mechanismen haben aber
wenn man sich anschaut
was passiert auf der welt da sieht man
dass die vorteile der demokratischen
ansätze ganz klar auf der hand liegen
ich denke nicht dass prothesen so einen
katastrophalen fehler gemacht hätte wenn
er dem rat wäre
er halte leute gehabt die gesagt hätten
das geht so nicht ich würde nur sagen
die demokratin verlieren manchmal die
erste hälfte im fußball spielen
vielleicht sollte ich kein fußballspiel
niemals beispiel weil wir meistens
verlieren gegen deutschland aber egal
ich ganz anders formulieren
demokratien brauche nur zeit bis sie ans
laufen kommen bei einem großen problemen
und dann wird es aber gelöst denen sie
malkovich
so als ob die chinesischen gesetze
richtig wer einen blog daran zu machen
und jetzt am schluss ist aber klar
geworden dass die großen demokratie in
der welt die g7 länder der welt die
impfstoffe produziert haben die dann
effektiv und jetzt sehen wir dass unsere
länder den london abgebaut haben und das
haben die chinesen eben leider nicht
oder wenn sie noch ein beispiel
wenn man sich die
so hoch gelobte militärischer maschine
der russen anschaut da kann doch auch
heraus dass die doch nie so gut
funktioniert wie man gedacht haben sehr
viele und geschosse sind eben
blindgänger
und das eben auf dem schlachtfeld nicht
mal gedacht hatten das heißt der
englisch sind die demokratien sind
vielleicht langsam der demokratische
prozess ist schmerzhaft aber
letztendlich gewinnen die demokratie
nach deutschland und zu den nachrichten
heinz die krankenkassen werden teurer
der durchschnittliche zusatzbeitrag für
die gesetzliche krankenversicherung soll
im kommenden jahr um 0,3 punkte auf 1,6
prozent angehoben werden das hat
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
angekündigt als eine von mehreren
maßnahmen um eine finanzierungslücke von
rund 17 milliarden euro zu schließen der
gesamtbeitrag läge dann bei 16,2 prozent
dazu setzt lauterbach auf mehr effizienz
im gesundheitssystem die pharmaindustrie
wieder mit einer sonderabgabe belastet
rücklagen der kassen sollen abschmelzen
und einen steuerzuschuss soll es geben
in nordrhein westfalen ist
ministerpräsident wüst vom landtag in
seinem amt bestätigt worden der
cdu-politiker steht künftig an der
spitze einer schwarz-grünen
regierungskoalition
morgen will wüst die ministerinnen und
minister seines kabinetts vorstellen
damit steht dann sechs wochen nach der
landtagswahl die neue landesregierung
das landgericht neuruppin hat einen mann
zu einer fünfjährigen haftstrafe
verurteilt wegen beihilfe zum mord und
versuchten mord als früherer wachmann im
kz sachsenhausen
mit seinem dienst habe der 101 jährige
bewusst terror und massenmord gefördert
so der vorsitzende richter der
verurteilte hatte seine schuld bis zum
ende des prozesses geleugnet sein
verteidiger kündigte revision zum
bundesgerichtshof an
die zahl der antisemitischen vorfälle in
deutschland ist im vergangenen jahr
weiter angestiegen das berichtet der
bundesverband der recherche und
informationsstellen antisemitismus in
seinem jahresbericht und listet
insgesamt
2738 fälle auf das sind im schnitt mehr
als 7 pro tag gegenüber dem vorjahr
bedeutet dies einen anstieg um 40
prozent allerdings hat auch die zahl der
meldestellen zugenommen trotzdem gehen
experten weiterhin von einer hohen
dunkelziffer aus
nahe der texanischen stadt san antonio
sind im anhänger eines abgestellten lkw
die leichen von 46 migranten entdeckt
worden mindestens 16 überlebende seien
erschöpft aus den überhitzten laderaum
gerettet und ins krankenhaus gebracht
worden so der lokale feuerwehrchef vier
von ihnen verstarben oder später die
polizei geht derzeit von einem schleuser
versuch aus mexiko aus drei verdächtige
wurden festgenommen
die kunst einen koalitionsvertrag zu
schmieden besteht bekanntlich auch darin
die kritischen punkte so zu formulieren
dass sich alle beteiligten darin
wiederfinden hat aber den kleinen
nachteil dass es dann auch nicht sehr
konkret sein kann über kurz oder lang
fällt an das auf die füße wenn es ans
regieren geht denn da wird's irgendwann
konkret so erging es gerade der ampel
koalition bei der frage ob und welche
zukunft autos mit verbrennungsmotoren
haben waren grüne und fdp von anfang an
uneins der aufgeschobene konflikt ist
nun eskaliert weil deutschland bei den
eu-verhandlungen eine haltung haben muss
die hat man heute schließlich gefunden
mit mühe die christiane hübscher
berichtet der ampel krimi beginnt
frühmorgens in luxemburg mit gleich zwei
deutschen ministern die hier das
eu-weite verbrenner aus mit beschließen
wollen also es ist ein tag wo wir gut
vorbereitet rein gehen als deutsche
bundesregierung abgestimmt und gut
vorbereitet reingehen doch nichts ist
abgestimmt zu hause in der
ampelkoalition nichts gut vorbereitet
wird sich gleich zeigen die grüne
umweltministerin glaubt da noch sie habe
einen deal mit der fdp ab 2035 keine
neuzulassung von pkw mehr die co2
ausstoßen wir werden aber
gleichzeitig noch mal klarstellen und
das war der fdp besonders wichtig dass
es auch bereiche gibt in denen auch
danach noch andere technologien zum
einsatz kommen können sei es im
flugverkehr im schiffsverkehr oder eben
für große lkws mit anderen technologien
mein lembke die sogenannten eve us-
synthetische kraftstoffe auch
klimaneutral aber noch in der
entwicklung die grünen wollen sie also
nur für spezialfahrzeuge erlauben in
berlin hört dass fdp chef lindner und
widerspricht die äußerungen der
umweltministerin zum verbrenner aus sind
überraschend sie entsprechen nicht den
verabredungen twittert lindner der ampel
klatsch ist perfekt die fdp besteht
darauf if you es müssten auch für alle
pkw möglich sein sonst könne es in
luxemburg eine deutsche zustimmung geben
der kanzler muss aus ellmau vermittelnd
eingreifen und unterstützt mal wieder
die sicht der fdp
dass
zum beispiel auch pkw die mit infos
betrieben werden oder auf andere weise
co2 neutral sind noch das licht der welt
erblicken dürfen um kurz nach 18 uhr hat
die ampel regierung in berlin endlich
einen kompromiss gefunden eine hintertür
für den verbrenner sozusagen und die
liebe rein beeilen sich es zu verkünden
die bundesregierung hat sich darauf
verständigt dass fahrzeuge mit
verbrennungsmotor auch nach 2035 neu
zugelassen werden sollen wenn sie
nachweislich nur mit fouls betrieben
werden die eu-kommission wird hierzu
einen konkreten regulierungs vorschlag
unterbreiten und zwar sowohl für pkw als
auch für leichte nutzfahrzeuge
damit ist der weg für eine zustimmung
heute im umweltministerrat frei und das
verbot des verbrennungsmotors vom tisch
nun kommt es auf die eu-umweltminister
an werden sie dem deutschen
kompromissvorschlag folgen auch andere
länder hatten vorher bedenken angemeldet
gegen ein komplettes verbrenner verbot
es könnte eine lange verhandlungsnacht
werden in luxemburg
1 macht nochmal weiter auch mit
wirtschaft die verbraucherstimmung in
deutschland setzt ihre talfahrt im juni
fort sagt das forschungsunternehmen gfk
und meldet den niedrigsten wert seit der
wiedervereinigung
frank bethmann das sind gleich mehrere
entwicklungen die da inzwischen so auf
die stimmung drücken ja da ist die
unsicherheit infolge der ukraine kriege
ist da ist aber auch die inzwischen
rekord hohe inflation beides gehört
zusammen beides treibt die
lebenshaltungskosten weiter nach oben
und drücke inzwischen schwer auf die
lust der verbraucher am einkaufen weiß
der gfk konjunktur experte rolf bürkl
wenn für energie und lebensmittel von
den privaten haushalten deutlich mehr
gezahlt werden muss stehen entsprechend
weniger finanzielle mittel vor allem für
größere anschaffungen zur verfügung
schon jetzt zeichnet sich ab die
nachzahlungen für strom und gas werden
so hoch ausfallen dass manche familien
überlegen ob sie sich den sommerurlaub
überhaupt noch leisten können jeder
einkauf im supermarkt ist teurer als der
davor die konsumenten verlieren nicht
nur real massiv an kaufkraft und können
sich daher weniger leisten kommentiert
dekabank ökonom andreas scheuerle die
entwicklung sie fühlen sich sogar noch
ärmer als sie eigentlich sind weil die
beiden täglichen konsum gefühlte
inflation um ein vielfaches über der
amtlich gemessenen inflationsrate liegt
während die konsumlaune also auf einem
bis dato nicht gekannten tiefpunkt
gefallen ist konnte der dax heute
abermals wenn auch nur leichte gewinne
verbuchen frank bethmann vielen dank
die frauenfußball wm rückt näher am 6
juli beginnt das turnier in england zwei
tage später hat dann die deutsche
mannschaft ihr erstes spiel noch ist das
team im trainingslager in herzogenaurach
und zum stand der dinge dort béla réthy
es sind die letzten tage der
vorbereitung auf die em die härteste
trainingsphase ist vorbei in zehn tagen
beginnt für deutschland das turnier mit
dem spiel
gegen dänemark wir haben noch nicht alle
bei hundert prozent aber das wussten wir
vorher immer noch ein paar tage zeit bis
zum ersten spiel bzw haben ja auch mehr
vor als nur drei spiele zu machen die
wichtigste nachricht alexandra popp ist
nach ihrer erkrankung zurück erzielte
auch das letzte tor zum 7 zu null beim
test gegen die schweiz klar muss man
auch sagen das glaube ich die schweiz
nicht in einem besten zustand war und
wir das schon noch ein bisschen
relativieren müssen das ganze aber das
ist uns allen definitiv bewusst dass es
gegen stärkere mannschaften ja nicht so
einfach geht am sonntag geht es dann
nach england mit dem flieger
das was an uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht es weiter mit der reportage reihe
37° heute mit dem titel dein ziel ist
mein weg über menschen die uns täglich
mit öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
befördern eine busfahrerin eine u bahn
fahrerin und ein fährmann erzählen über
ihr leben und nah sein möchte mir meldet
sich dann gegen 0.40 mit unserem
heutigen update kommt die meldung morgen
wieder auf wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir bekommen neue
gewitter mit diesem tief hier war es
quasi über oberitalien liegt und hier
nun etwas regen bringt wird es herrscht
dort eine extreme dürre schon seit
wochen hat es kaum geregnet und dieses
tief das wandert über die alpen zu uns
und wird auch bei uns dann für schauer
und gewitter sorgen in den nächsten
stunden und auch morgen schauen wir uns
das genau an in der nacht wachsen die
gewitter aus den alpen heraus richtung
norden richtung erzgebirge
ansonsten bleibt es dann nach westen
eher trocken und die temperaturen sinken
auf 17 grad zum beispiel im südosten 9
grad im hessischen bergland morgen im
tagesverlauf weitere schauer und
gewitter mit diesem tief die können
durchaus auch unwetterartig ausfallen
das bedeutet viel regen kurzer zeit es
kann durchaus 20 bis 30 liter bei
gewittern dann geben nach westen es ist
trocken nach norden sogar häufig sonnig
und das bei höchsten temperaturen von 29
grad ganz im westen deutschlands 22 grad
gibt es zum beispiel nach süden hin oder
an der ostsee die nächsten tage am
donnerstag gibt es einzelne schauer und
gewitter temperaturen knapp über der 30
grad marke am freitag gibt es weitere
gewitter und samstag bleibt komplett
trocken bei 27 grad maximal damit
wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen abend